what's going on everybody welcome to
another python 3 basics tutorial video
in this video what we're going to be
talking about is multi-dimensional lists
so all the lists that we've covered so
far have been a singular dimension right
there's just for each
um
bit of data in the list it's only one
bit of data but actually you can have
lists within lists
within lists within lists if you want
you can go as deep as you want you can
get very convoluted fast
so anyway what we're going gonna be
showing today is a two-dimensional list
and then you could take it from there if
you so chose so with that let's go ahead
and get started so uh let's say we have
a list and right now like a typical list
don't forget your square brackets let's
just say we have uh this can't get away
from these massive numbers this is our
list for now okay
uh and in fact let's make that shorter
otherwise i'm gonna cry
so we have this list right now so we've
got a five a six a six and a two let's
just make this a 7
so what we can do now this is a one
dimensional list but what we can do is
we can make it a two dimensional list so
each element in this list is just
actually another list
so 5 and 6 and then we have a 6 and
a seven
and then a seven
and a two
and then a two and a five anybody see
what i did there probably not anyway
continuing on
um so now we have a two-dimensional list
so for one we can just print x save and
run that
apparently this is a really challenging
there we go okay so here's our list now
uh let's say we want to print the first
element here
it's a six and a seven now what if we
wanted to go even deeper well we can go
deeper uh using the same sort of syntax
so we can say we want the first element
or the zeroth element which will be
hopefully
a six right we have six seven the first
of that is a six save and run it and we
get a six
so that's how we can reference that now
we could go even further right so this
is a two dimensional list we could take
this even further and say like these
numbers here
this could be a list as well and then we
could have another list here
um
then another list
uh let me make sure i've done this right
this gets messy very fast yeah which is
what i'm about to talk about here um
six six
and then
seven
eight
um i'll leave it like that for now we
don't actually have to go further let me
make sure that's a valid list okay
so
um
so this printed now you can see this is
you know two elements so let's say you
know you want to go even further well
obviously we still can go further so the
zero with the zero with again a six
now as you can see
and just typing this out was a kind of a
pain also just visually looking at it
it's kind of a pain to look at this
uh so what you can do when you make big
lists like this is see like with python
we don't have to have very nice
standards necessarily all the time it
kind of python like forces us into
having standards so as a programmer you
maybe forget the fact that you might
need to program your own standards and
again what i mean by standards is the
organization of all the text here
so but what you can do with lists tuples
or really a whole bunch of stuff but
mostly you're going to do it with lists
is you can do the following you can hit
enter and now this is the you know i'm
pointing to the screen you can't see
that
uh so like this is our our opening
bracket and then we might as well put
our closing bracket right down there as
well
and then this is our second bracket here
and if you ever want to know um you know
what each bracket corresponds to
uh you can kind of you can do this oops
you can delete and add it and you can
see how it highlights everything that's
kind of how you know like what that
bracket corresponds to so if you're used
to like i say code in like a notepad
plus plus this sometimes it does it
automatically for you if you like
highlight the little bracket especially
at curly braces so you're programming i
don't know php or something you
highlight them and it kind of
corresponds so if you ever want to know
like what bracket that is or if you've
actually closed everything you could
just do that
um so anyway then we can see you know
these are their own little pair and this
is a group here
and then you can either put the commas
at the bottom or i like to leave them at
the end like this um i'm pointing to the
screen again you can't see
like this at the end here because uh you
can go like this and then everything is
nice and organized and then do it one
more time this didn't have any lists
within the list so it's not as pretty
and organized but you get the idea
um so we can still run this though
and python you know still deals with it
and handles it just like you would hope
and then here let me show you that
we'll run it same thing so you can add
spaces and it's okay so if you you know
if you're kind of ocd about making
everything look pretty um you can get
away with it
so anyway uh that's just some an example
of multi-dimensional lists again you can
go as deep into this as you want and it
just helps to organize i'm just keep
pointing at the screen
needed like a camera behind me so you
guys can see what i'm pointing at
you can organize it like this and
obviously as you get more and more
dimensions it's going to get almost
impossible right because your screen is
you know still only two dimensions so
as soon as you get past the
two-dimensional list you're kind of
screwed again but
anyway it does help to kind of organize
it a little bit so
that's going to conclude uh this video
if you guys have any questions or
comments please feel free to leave them
below as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions until next time